I'm looking at some of the country's
finest drugs of course young lows are in
a go-kart over there people love great
bank robbery stories so let's give them
something bowling stainless and Bradys
in it to talk about over there lot some
right in it that's my baby would be
driver
[Music]
are you just starting your day or did
you just get off hey call I know you
know so what is it you do I'm a driver
Oh like you're so far
anyone I'd know
I don't know what is your name baby your
name's baby Bab Wahby
[Music]
just wanna say listen to the music all
the time making a mental mental meaning
slow was he slow no he had an accident
when he was a kid still has a hum in the
drum plays music to drown it out and
that's what makes him the best
[Music]
one more job and I'm done one more job
and we're straight now I don't think I
need to give you a speech at all what
happens when you say no how I could
break your legs and tell everyone you
love because you are you know that onion
yeah the moment you catch feelings
there's a moment your kitchen bully and
you're a waitress girlfriends you keep
it that way
I want us to have oyster never stop
he wouldn't I mean baby
[Music]
these day baby you got to get blood on
your hands confers music
baby can you get out of here have to end
there are we in bed together now baby
baby
doc said microwaves this is Mike Myers
it should be the Halloween man Bella we
met no the killer dual from Halloween
are giving Jason no baby you tell me who
does
[Music]
she good girl me love them yes I do
that's too bad
you